THEY WANT 99.9% LIBERAL VOICES
ON THE AIR.
TUCKER, GREAT JOB.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
I HAVE A SPECIAL MESSAGE FOR JIM
COMEY.
FOR NEARLY TWO YEARS, THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, WE
HAVE SOMEHOW MANAGED TO SURVIVE
WITHOUT THE DEDICATED
STEWARDSHIP OF OUR RIGHTEOUS
MORAL SAVIOR, THE EVER SO
VIRTUOUS AND HONORABLE JAMES
COMEY.
THANKFULLY HE'S BACK AND TELLING
ALL OF US WE ARE THE STUPID,
SMELLY, WALMART SHOPPERS OF
AMERICA.
HIS COLLEAGUE PETER STRZOK,
THAT'S HOW HE REFERS TO US.
HE'S TELLING US HOW TO BEHAVE AS
THE MUELLER WITCH HUNT NEARS ITS
CONCLUSION.
WE ARE GOING TO SHOW YOU WHAT
THE INDIGNANT, TOTALLY
DISGRACED, FIRED FBI DIRECTOR
HAD TO SAY.
WE ARE GOING TO REMIND YOU OF
ALL ABOUT JAMES COMEY AND WHY
THE PRESIDENT DID THE COUNTRY A
FAVOR BY FIRING HIM.
ALL RIGHT, BUT FIRST, WE'LL GET
TO THAT IN A MINUTE.
IT'S TIME FOR OUR ONGOING
HANNITY WATCH ON THE RADICAL
SOCIALIST DEMOCRATIC 2020
CANDIDATES.
WE START TONIGHT WITH REALLY
MORE BIZARRE BEHAVIOR FROM
ROBERT FRANCIS BETO BOZO OR WOR
WORK.
NO TABLE IS SAFE IN AMERICA.
ROBERT FRANCIS SEEMS TO FORCE
HIS WAY INTO EVERY RESTAURANT,
EVERY DINER IN THE GREAT STATE
OF IOWA AND APPEARS THAT HE'S
FALLEN IN LOVE WITH THESE
ELEVATED SURFACES.
WHATEVER HE DOES.
COVER YOUR FOOD, COVER YOUR
DRINKS BECAUSE BETO IS COMING TO
A TOWN NEAR YOU AND APPARENTLY
HE IS STOMPING ALL OVER WHERE
YOU ACTUALLY EAT.
PERHAPS HE'S JUST TRYING TO
SPREAD THE MAGICAL HEALING
POWERS OF WHAT WE TOLD YOU LAST
NIGHT OF EATING DIRT.
WHICH HE DID.
I LOT OF IT.
AFTER HE LOST TO TED CRUZ NORTH
NEW MEXICO AND HE THINKS THEY
HAVE SUPER NATURAL POWERS.
BY THE WAY, HE ACTUALLY EVEN
BROUGHT SOME HOME FOR HIS FAMILY
TO EAT.
WHAT A GENEROUS GIFT.
OF COURSE HIS BEHAVIOR ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL, IT PALES IN
COMPARISON TO HIS EXTREME AND 90
IDEAS.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE WE NOW KNOW
THAT BETO, HIS ALL-OUT WAR
AGAINST BORDER WALLS, NOT ONLY
IS HE AGAINST THE PRESIDENT'S
PLAN FOR EXPANDING BORDER
SECURITY BUT HE ALSO WANTS TO
TEAR DOWN EXISTING BORDER WALLS
SO OUR BORDERS THEN WOULD BE
COMPLETELY WIDE OPEN.
BECAUSE, ACCORDING TO BETO,
THERE ARE NO PROBLEMS, NONE, AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DO NOT NEED ANY WALLS.
$30 BILLION, 2,000 MILES LONG,
30 FEET HIGH.
IT WILL NOT BE BUILT ON THE
INTERNATIONAL BOUNDARY LINE
WHICH IS THE CENTER LINE OF THE
RIO GRANDE RIVER.
THE WALL WILL BE BILLED WELL
INTO THE INTERIOR OF SOMEONE'S
RANCH, SOMEONE ELSE'S FARM,
SOMEONE ELSE'S HOME.
YOU AND I WILL BE FORCED TO TAKE
THEIR PROPERTIES TO SOLVE A
PROBLEM THAT WE DO NOT HAVE.
>> Sean: THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WE'VE CHRONICLED, THE YOUNG
GIRLS IN PROSTITUTION, DRUG
TRAFFICKING, VIOLENT GANGS,
CARTELS, THE 2%, NOT THE 98%.
200 AMERICANS KILLED EVERY WEEK
FROM HEROIN, 90% CROSSES THAT
BORDER.
I GUESS NONE OF THAT SEEMS TO
MATTER TO ROBERT FRANCIS O
ROURKE.
I GUESS THE ANGEL MOMS AND DADS
WHO WE HAVE INTERVIEWED WHO HAVE
LOST THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS AND
THEIR CHILDREN FROM HEROIN
OVERDOSES, I GUESS HE ISN'T
PAYING ATTENTION TO THEM.
MAYBE HE NEEDS A LONG
CONVERSATION WITH THEM BECAUSE
THAT CROSSES OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
AND I GUESS NONE OF THE SEEMS TO
MATTER OR MAYBE HE'S JUST LIVING
IN AN ALTERNATIVE REALITY FROM
INGESTING TOO MUCH DIRT.
EITHER WAY, HE'S IN GOOD COMPANY
WITHIN HIS OWN PARTY.
FOR EXAMPLE, FELLOW DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ NOW THE LEADER
PUSHING THE BIZARRE FAR LEFT
RADICAL IDEAS.
THESE ARE NOT BASED ON REALITY.
SHE WANTS TO BAN ALL AIR TRAVEL,
GET RID OF THE COMBUSTION
ENGINE, AND ALL OIL AND GAS IN
TEN YEARS AND CLOUDS BECAUSE OF
IMPENDING APOCALYPSE.
SHE ACTUALLY THINKS THE WORLD IS
GOING TO END IN 12 YEARS.
BUT THAT DIDN'T STOP HER FROM
TOURING THIS MASSIVE $8 BILLION
EXPANSION OF LaGUARDIA AIRPORT
IN NEW YORK CITY.
THAT'S HER DISTRICT.
IT ISN'T THAT THE VERY THING SHE
WANTS TO BAN?
HERE SHE IS CHEERING ON THE
EXPANSION OF THAT AIRPORT RIGHT
IN HER HOME CITY.
THIS IS THE AIRPORT SHE UTILIZES
WE KNOW AN AWFUL LOT.
YOU CAN TAKE AMTRAK BETWEEN
NEW YORK AND D.C. WHICH HE
PREFERS TO TRAVEL VIA DELTA, THE
SHUTTLE.
IT'S A DO AS I SAY, NOT AS I DO,
KIND OF LIKE THE SOCIALIST WAY.
RIGHT, CONGRESSWOMAN?
THIS KIND OF RAMPANT HYPOCRISY
DOESN'T MATTER TO THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA AT ALL.
LOOK AT "TIME" MAGAZINE.
JUST FEATURED HERMITS COVER,
CALLING HER "THE PHENOM."
MORE ON THAT RADICAL FAR LEFT
SOCIALIST DEMOCRAT PARTY IN
THEIR BEST FRIENDS IN THE MEDIA
JUST A MINUTE.
ALSO TONIGHT THE GREAT ONE, MARK
LEVIN WILL BE WITH US AND THE
EVER SO BRILLIANT VICTOR DAVID
HANSON.
FIRST WE DO TURN TO SOME GOOD
NEWS BEFORE WE GET TO OUR TOP
STORY OUT OF SYRIA.
REMEMBER 2015, THEN CANDIDATE
DONALD TRUMP MADE THIS PROMISE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THEY WANT TO GO AFTER OUR
CIVILIANS.
THEY WANT TO KILL NOT ONLY OUR
CIVILIANS ALL OVER THE WORLD AND
IT'S GOT TO BE STOPPED.
IT'S GOING TO BE STOPPED.
SOMEBODY CRITICIZED ME THE OTHER
DAY BECAUSE THEY ASKED ME WHAT I
DO AND I SAID I'M GOING TO BOMB
THE [BLEEP]
OUT OF THEM.
I DON'T CARE.
THEY'VE GOT TO BE STOPPED.
>> Sean: VERY DIFFERENT
POLITICIAN.
PROMISES MADE A LOT OF PROMISES
KEPT.
THOSE INSANE RULES OF ENGAGEMENT
FROM THE OBAMA ERA WERE LIFTED,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS UNLEASHED
AMERICAN AIRPOWER, BOMBING ISIS
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
WITH THE HELP OF THAT AIR COVER,
THE U.S. BACKED SYRIAN FORCES
JUST CLEARED WHAT IS THE FINAL
STRIP OF LAND ONCE HELD BY ISIS
FIGHTERS, THE ONE THEY TOOK OVER
ORIGINALLY.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF RADICAL
JIHADISTS HAVE SURRENDERED.
MANY OTHER THOUSANDS HAVE BEEN
KILLED, THE SO-CALLED CALIPHATE
IS NO MORE.
THE STRUGGLE AGAINST RADICAL
EXTREMISM AND THOSE SYMPATHETIC
TO ISIS, WE MUST FOREVER
REMAINED VIGILANT.
THE PRESIDENT RECOGNIZED:
HEIGHTS HAS ISRAEL TERRITORY.
AGAIN HE WAS THE ONLY PRESIDENT
TO PROMISE JERUSALEM IS THE
RIGHTFUL CAPITAL.
HE MADE IT HAPPEN.
WE TURN OUR ATTENTION TO HANNITY
WATCH AND THIS IS OUR TOP STORY
TONIGHT.
THE SEEMINGLY NEVER-ENDING PROBE
APPEARS TO BE IN ITS FINAL
STAGE.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS MUELLER'S
FULL REPORT RELEASED TO THE
PUBLIC.
HE DOESN'T DECIDE THAT THAT HE
WANTS EVERYONE EVERYWHERE TO SEE
IT WITH HER OWN EYES.
THAT AFTER NINE MONTHS, BY THE
WAY, OF INVESTIGATIONS FROM
COMEY AND HIS HAVE VI, THAT WAS
BEFORE MUELLER, THE NEARLY 700
DAYS OF INVESTIGATIONS FROM
EULER, WE KNOW THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE OF ANY TRANS-RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, NONE, ZERO, NOTHING.
REMEMBER WE LEARNED LAST WEEK,
LISA PAGE, PETER STRZOK
TESTIFIED THAT THE FBI'S
NINE-MONTH INVESTIGATION BEFORE
THE APPOINTMENT OF MUELLER CAME
UP EMPTY.
THEY HAD NOTHING.
THE HOUSE, SENATE
INVESTIGATIONS, THEY ALSO CAME
UP EMPTY.
NOTHING.
LOOK AT THIS NBC NEWS PANICKING.
THEY ARE WORRIED.
THEY RECENTLY RAN A REPORT
ENTITLED "YOU MAY BE
DISAPPOINTED BY THE MUELLER
REPORT."
IN OTHER WORDS, THE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES THAT THEIR NETWORK HAS
BEEN BATTLING FOR TWO PLUS YEARS
MIGHT BE ABOUT TO BE CONFRONTED
WITH TRUTH.
MEANWHILE THE EVER VIRTUOUS
SAVIOR OF AMERICAN MORALITY, HIS
BACK AND HE'S TELLING YOU
EXACTLY WHAT YOU NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THE IMPENDING SPECIAL
COUNSEL REPORT.
IN AN OP-ED IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THE ALWAYS
SANCTIMONIOUS, SELF-RIGHTEOUS
JIM COMEY WRITING THAT HE'S NOT
ROOTING FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
BE GUILTY OF A CRIME.
INSTEAD HE'S "ROOTING FOR A
DEMONSTRATION TO THE WORLD THAT
THE UNITED STATES JUSTICE SYSTEM
WORKS."
REALLY?
WELL, JIM COMEY, I DON'T BELIEVE
A SINGLE WORD YOU SAY.
TIME NOW FOR A HANNITY HISTORY
LESSONS ON JAMES COMEY.
AND HIS ROLE IN ALL OF THIS.
HE IS THE ROOT OF ALMOST
EVERYTHING HERE.
JAMES COMEY, HE WAS THE ONE WHO
TOTALLY MISHANDLED AND HELPED
RIGGED THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION.
HE'S THE ONE THAT ALLOWED
OBAMA'S ATTORNEY GENERAL LORETTA
LYNCH TO DICTATE HOW HIS AGENCY
WAS CONDUCTING THE INVESTIGATIO
INVESTIGATION.
OR SHOULD I SAY MATTER?
WHICH HE ALLOWED HER TO SAY WHEN
HE KNEW IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE AN
INVESTIGATION.
HE WAS LEAVING IT.
JIM COMEY, THE ONE WHO OVERSAW
CLINTON'S EXONERATION LETTER IN
MAY OF 2016, THREE MONTHS BEFORE
THE INVESTIGATION ENDED AND
THREE MONTHS BEFORE
HILLARY CLINTON, OTHER KEY
WITNESSES, WERE EVEN
INTERVIEWED.
WHAT I CALL THE EXONERATION
BEFORE INVESTIGATION.
BY THE WAY, IT WAS HE ALLOWED TO
OTHER PEOPLE IN THE ROOM WITH
HILLARY WHEN SHE WAS BEING
INTERROGATED.
SUPPOSEDLY.
HE'S THE ONE THAT SIGNED OFF ON
CHANGING THE ALL IMPORTANT
LANGUAGE IN THE LETTER, THE
EXONERATION LETTER.
GROSS NEGLIGENCE WAS TAKEN OUT.
THAT WOULD BE THE CRIMINAL
STATUTE.
THE WORDS "EXTREME CARELESSNESS"
PUT IN AND THEN OF COURSE THEY
HAD THE NEWS STANDARD INTENT
THAT THEY JUST MADE UP IN THE
LAW.
WHICH IS NOT ALL AT THE
DIRECTION OF OBAMA'S DOJ WHICH
WE LEARNED LAST WEEK, IN LORETTA
LYNCH'S OFFICE, SHE'S
TAKING CONTROL OF ALL OF THIS,
ACCORDING TO PAGE AT STRZOK.
JIM COMEY IS THE ONE THAT LIED
ABOUT ALL OF THIS ON
CAPITOL HILL.
HE TESTIFIED THAT HE DIDN'T
WRITE THE EXONERATION LETTER
BEFORE INTERVIEWING CLINTON.
THAT WAS A LIE.
HE WAS THE ONE WHO ALLOWED
RAMPANT ANTI-TRUMP BIAS TO
FESTER AMONG HIS TOP OFFICIALS
INCLUDING PAGE, STRZOK,
McCABE, AND SO MANY MORE.
IT WAS JIM COMEY WHO ALLOW THE
PERSON THERE CALLED TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, US, SMELLY WALMART
PEOPLE AND VOWED TO STOP DRUM
FROM BECOMING PRESIDENT.
HE LET HIM LEAD THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND HE'S THE GUY WHO
INTERVIEWED HILLARY.
BY THE WAY, IT WAS JIM COMEY WHO
PURPOSELY LEAK SENSITIVE
INFORMATION AND GOVERNMENT MEMOS
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT AFTER HE WAS
UNCEREMONIOUSLY WELL, FIRED, AND
HE DID IT FOR THE VERY PURPOSES
OF ENSURING THAT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL INVESTIGATION HAPPENED
AFTER HIS OWN NINE-MONTH
INVESTIGATION GOT NOTHING.
AND THAT HIS GOOD FRIEND ROBERT
MUELLER WAS APPOINTED TO LEAD
THE WITCH HUNT EVEN THOUGH,
AGAIN, THEY HAD FOUND NOTHING.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THIS.
>> THE PRESIDENT TWEETED ON
FRIDAY AFTER I GOT FIRED THAT I
BETTER HOPE THERE'S NOT TAPES.
I WOKE UP IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT ON MONDAY NIGHT BECAUSE IT
DIDN'T DAWN ON THE ORIGINALLY
THAT THERE MIGHT BE
CORROBORATION FOR OUR
CONVERSATION.
THERE MIGHT BE A TAPE.
MY JUDGMENT WAS I NEEDED TO GET
THAT OUT INTO THE PUBLIC SQUARE
AND SO I ASKED A FRIEND OF MINE
TO SHARE THE CONTENT OF THE MEMO
WITH A REPORTER.
I DIDN'T DO IT MYSELF FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS BUT I ASKED
THEM TO BECAUSE I THOUGHT THAT
MIGHT PROMPT THE APPOINTMENT OF
A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> Sean: JIM COMEY, HE ALSO
SIGNED THE FIRST DEVICE
APPLICATION.
THIS WAS IN OCTOBER OF 2016.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT WAS JIM COMEY
WHO CLEARLY WE NOW KNOW
COMMITTED FRAUD WITH HIS
SIGNATURE BEFORE A FISA COURT
JUDGE.
WHAT DID HE USE?
THE BULK OF INFORMATION,
NEWNESS, GRASSLEY, GRAHAM MEMO
TELLS US HILLARY CLINTON'S
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DIRTY RUSSIN
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DIRTY RUSSID
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DIRTY RUSSIS
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DIRTY RUSSII
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DIRTY RUSSIR
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DIRTY RUSSI.
IT WAS CALLED ME IN FACT WHO HID
THE FACT THAT THE DOSSIERS
CONTENTS, SMALL DETAIL, HILLARY
PAID FOR IT BUT THEY DIDN'T TELL
THE FISA COURT IN BIG BOLD
LETTERS SHE PAID FOR IT THAT
THIS WAS A PARTISAN DOCUMENT,
UNVERIFIED, UNCORROBORATED.
THAT WOULD BE CALLED IN MY WORLD
FRAUD BY OMISSION.
SMALL OVERSIGHT, MR. COMEY?
IT WAS JIM COMEY WHO SIGNED OFF
ON THAT DOCUMENT THAT WAS
COMPLETELY, THINK ABOUT THIS,
UNVERIFIABLE.
HOW DO WE KNOW IT'S
UNVERIFIABLE?
ITS AUTHOR, CHRISTOPHER STEELE,
TESTIFIED IN GREAT BRITAIN HE
HAD NO IDEA IF ANY OF THAT
DOSSIER WAS TRUE.
WE NOW KNOW MOST OF IT IS
TOTALLY DEBUNKED, BUT THAT'S
WHAT THEY PRESENTED TO THE FISA
COURT JUDGE.
NOW, I THOUGHT IF I REMEMBER
CORRECTLY, A FISA APPLICATION
CAN ONLY BE OBTAINED IF A CAREER
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL SWEARS
THAT THE INFORMATION IS TRUE AND
CORRECT.
OR ELSE THERE WILL BE SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES.
WHERE DID I LEARN THAT FROM?
OH, ROD ROSENSTEIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> VICE APPLICATIONS ACTUALLY, A
WARRANT, LIKE A SEARCH WARRANT.
IN ORDER TO GET A FISA SEARCH
WARRANT, YOU NEED AN AFFIDAVIT
SIGNED BY A CAREER FEDERAL
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER WHO SWEARS
THAT THE INFORMATION IN THE
AFFIDAVIT IS TRUE AND CORRECT TO
THE BEST OF HIS KNOWLEDGE AND
BELIEF.
THAT'S THE WAY WE OPERATE.
IF IT'S WRONG -- SOMETIMES IT IS
-- IF YOU FIND OUT THERE'S
SOMETHING INCORRECT, THAT PERSON
IS GOING TO FACE CONSEQUENCES.
>> Sean: JIM COMEY PUT HIS
SIGNATURES WEARING THAT TO THE
BEST OF HIS KNOWLEDGE IT'S TRUE
AND ACCURATE.
WELL, EVEN ITS OWN AUTHOR
DOESN'T BELIEVE THAT.
BY THE WAY, NOW HE'S GOING TO
LECTURE US ON HOW WE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO JUDGE
THE MUELLER REPORT THAT HE SET
UP.
NONE OF THIS WOULD'VE HAPPENED,
NONE OF IT, EXCEPT JIM COMEY
ALLOWED HIS PERSONAL AMBITION,
HIS ANIMUS, HIS HATRED OF
DONALD TRUMP GET IN THE WAY.
HOW DO YOU SIGN OFF ON A WARRANT
THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO VERIFY?
HOW DO YOU DO THAT?
WHEN CHRISTOPHER STEELE SAID YOU
CAN'T VERIFY IT, HE CAN'T VERIFY
CAN'T VERIFY IT, HE CAN'T VERIFI
CAN'T VERIFY IT, HE CAN'T VERIF,
CAN'T VERIFY IT, HE CAN'T VERIFO
CAN'T VERIFY IT, HE CAN'T VERIFL
CAN'T VERIFY IT, HE CAN'T VERIFY
50/50 CHANCE IT'S TRUE, HOW DO
YOU HIDE FROM A JUDGE HILLARY
PAID FOR THAT DOSSIER?
THE OPPOSITION PARTY PAID FOR
IT.
AND THREE MONTHS AFTER HE SIGNED
THE OCTOBER 2016 WARRANT, WELL,
THEN HE WENT TO TRUMP TOWER
JANUARY 2017 AND TOLD THEN
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP THAT THE
DOSSIER EXISTS.
IT'S UNVERIFIED.
AND IT'S SALACIOUS.
THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT HE WOULD'VE
SIGNED OFF ON IN OCTOBER.
BASED ON THE GARBAGE BEING
TRUTHFUL THREE MONTHS EARLIER,
WHAT HE SWORE TO.
THAT'S CALLED FRAUD.
THAT'S CALLED LYING.
THAT'S CALLED A FRAUD THAT ALSO
-- THINK ABOUT THIS.
IT DENIED ONE OF OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT.
THAT WOULD BE CARTER PAGE.
FRAUD BECAUSE THE MEDIA,
"THE WASHINGTON POST," FRAUD
LEAKED BEFORE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT INFLUENCED THE
ELECTION WITH RUSSIAN LIES,
FRAUD THAT WAS USED TO ELECT A
CANDIDATE HE AND OTHERS
PREFERRED.
TRIED TO BLUDGEON A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT AND TO UNDO THE
ELECTION BECAUSE HE KNEW BETTER.
BECAUSE HE HATED TRUMP, JUST
LIKE HIS DISCIPLES, STRZOK AND
PAGE.
FIRST THING REAGAN
INVESTIGATION.
BY THE WAY, MR. COMEY, DO YOU
THINK IF I DELETED SUBPOENAED
EMAILS AND I ACID WASH MY HARD
DRIVE AND HAD SOMEBODY BUST MY
DEVICES, DO YOU THINK I WOULD
GET AWAY WITH THAT?
I DON'T THINK SO BUT THEY
CLEARED HILLARY OF ALL CHARGES.
THEY RIGGED THAT INVESTIGATION.
NOW HE THOUGHT HE KNEW BETTER
THAN YOU.
WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
TO THIS DAY, COMEY THINKS HE'S
AN AMERICAN SUPER PATRIOT.
HE'S NOT.
THIS HAS NOTHING TO DO BY THE
WAY WITH RANK-AND-FILE FBI
PEOPLE.
JIM COMEY TAINTED WHAT IS THE
GREATEST LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
IN THE WORLD.
HE DID THAT.
THANKS TO HIS HORRIBLE
LEADERSHIP, HIS ACTIONS AND
DECISIONS AS A DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI.
WE NOW HAVE SERIOUS DOUBTS IN
THIS COUNTRY AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW